in the previous videos we learnt that it
is possible to have square root of a
negative number but it involved using a
new number I which is equal to the
square root of negative 1
these numbers are called imaginary
numbers and could be of the form bi
where B is a real number and I is equal
to square root of negative 1 numbers
like I - I negative 4i are all imaginary
numbers what if we have a number like 3
plus 7 I will this be an imaginary
number well we can be sure that this
part of the number is imaginary and this
part is a real number so this is a mix
of real and imaginary parts and this is
what we call an example of a complex
number real plus imaginary gives us a
complex number it's of the form a plus
bi where a and B are real numbers and I
is the unit imaginary number now let's
play around with this basic form observe
that when a is equal to 0 what is left
will be an imaginary number and when B
is equal to 0 we only have a real number
so what are the real and imaginary parts
in the basic form of a complex number a
is called the real part and B I is
called the imaginary part now let me ask
you something interesting
when will the two complex numbers a plus
bi and c plus di be equal they will be
equal only if both the conditions are
satisfied first a is equal to C and
second B is equal to D yes only if a is
equal to C and B is equal to D will the
two complex numbers be equal real parts
equal and the imaginary parts as well
are equal however the real numbers are
comprehensible why are we moving towards
complex numbers do they lead to anything
worthwhile
doubts about it even among
mathematicians who initially developed
this concept while some did not believe
in them others were desperately trying
to prove their existence still the
journey continued and complex numbers
were finally allowed by mathematicians
today the most people may find complex
numbers incomprehensible or difficult to
understand they do exist in some form
and serve the purpose of understanding
of nature engineers use it to study
stresses on beams phenomena of resonance
and the flow of fluid around objects
such as water around a pipe they make it
easy to understand the flow of current
through electronic circuits using
resistances inductance and capacitors
they are also used in electromagnetism
where rather than trying to describe an
electromagnetic field by two real
quantities separately they are described
as a single complex number of which
electric and magnetic components are
simply the real and imaginary parts how
exactly are they used here well it's an
advanced topic which we will cover in a
graduation level math videos
[Music]